SPEAKER: Hello,
welcome to the session
on building the right API team.
As part of this
video, we'll talk you
through our
recommendations when it
comes to forming your API
team, the responsibilities,
and the various roles involved.
So to start things
off, let's take a look
at the digital value chain.
You might have seen
this diagram before.
But to briefly explain,
the digital value chain
shows the relationship
between the various teams
and technologies from
the aimed consumer
all the way down to
the back end systems.
For this session, will
be focusing specifically
on the API team shown
here in the chain.
The API team builds, yep,
you guessed it, the APIs.
This is the team that will be
working directly with your API
platform to create lovable
APIs for your app developers.
In terms of responsibility,
the API team owns 5 core areas.
First is building
highly consumable APIs.
The keyword here is consumable.
We recommend approaching API
design and implementation
from the outside in,
rather than the inside out.
What this means is that
the API team will always
need to keep the end consumer
in mind when approaching APIs
in the case of our
digital value chain,
this is the app developer.
The API team should
always be asking itself,
if I were an app developer,
what type of APIs what
I want to consume?
Second is learning and applying
best practices to the APIs
that they will be building.
We promote a variety of
industry best practices
when it comes to the design,
development, and the deployment
of your APIs.
Please refer to the Docs page
or a self-service training
on Kyocera for
additional details.
Third is engagement.
Similar to our focus
on consumable APIs,
the API team should be
engaged with all the players
in the digital value chain.
This includes back
end system teams,
which the APIs will front,
to the app developer,
in order to gain valuable
insights to unearth areas
to further iterate on and to
enhance your existing services.
Scalability is
also very important
when it comes to
your API program.
Oftentimes, we see that the API
team starts small, but grows
rapidly as more and more
demand comes down the pipeline.
In these scenarios, federation
becomes very important.
The API team owns the
creation and the management
of materials that allows
for the entire organization
to rapidly scale.
This includes things like the
API playbook, automated test
suites, and more.
Finally, API should
always be improving.
By leveraging capabilities
of the platforms,
such as analytics, the API team
can gain valuable insight into
who's using the APIs and how.
This information
allows the API team
to find areas of improvement and
enhancements based on real data
that they are seeing.
Remember our focus
on consumability?
This information can help
a lot with that we strongly
believe in the fast
and iterative approach
to development.
Market shifts happen,
rapidly and your API team
needs to be able to adapt and
be flexible in its delivery
approach.
As a result, we
recommend a methodology
such as agile for your program.
Similarly, the API team is
composed in a similar fashion
to a standard scrum team.
A diverse set of perspectives
is also very important,
which we'll cover more detail
when we talk about roles.
Having different viewpoints
that encompass the business,
technical, and
operational views,
will streamline your
API development process.
So now that we've
covered the basics,
let's jump into the individual
roles of an API team.
There are 5 main roles when
it comes to a good API team.
They are the API team
leader, the architect,
the API developers,
the evangelists,
and the extended team.
Let's spend the next few
minutes going over each one.
The API team leader is
essentially a product owner.
Now note that I said product
owner and not project manager.
As mentioned before, the
API team we're suggesting
is based off the
standard scrum model.
So the API team
leader is essentially
your product owner in scrum.
As such, the team
leader should be
aligned with both the
business and the IT,
and have a good understanding
of the needs of the consumer,
for example, the app developer.
The team leader also helps
create, refine, and prioritize
the scope for the API team.
When it comes down to
it, the team leader
will be the one that makes the
call if trade offs are needed
in the event that the API team
doesn't have the bandwidth
to complete all the items.
The architect is
critical to the API team.
Not only do they bridge the
gap between the API team
leader and the API
developers, they also
establish and enforce
API best practices
and keep a common
design cadence.
Their approach to
the API design is
consumer focused and educates
the wider API team on how
to leverage the API Platform.
In summary, they're part
designer, part teacher,
and part enforcer.
The API developers is your
core development group.
At the end of the day,
these are the folks that
are going to get the job done.
The API developers will
look to the API team
leader for guidance on the
scope and the architect
for their design principles.
They will then take those inputs
and build out the actual APIs.
As you would expect,
the API developers
should be very familiar
with the API Platform.
Without the API
developers, nothing
will get built, so be
sure you're nice them.
The evangelist's is the
mascot for the API program.
They're responsible for not
only outreaching to your API
consumers, but also
creating and nurturing
a developer community.
They can provide
valuable feedback
from the field, which
can then directly
impact the direction
of the API program.
A good evangelist will
be critical in expanding
the audience of your
APIs, both within
and outside of
your organization.
The extended team is also very
important in getting your APIs
out to production.
The extended team covers
organizations such as security,
QA, operations, and others.
The extended team
and their processes
may vary depending on how
your organization is set up.
But the key takeaway
is that these teams
should support rather than
obstruct your time to market.
So before we wrap up, let's
cover some common attributes
that all successful
API teams have.
First, a successful API
team should have the support
of an executive sponsor.
Chances are, the API
team will continue
to push the envelope
of innovation
within your organization.
So having a strong
executive sponsor
can help clear any
of those roadblocks
that they may face when
challenging the status quo.
Second, the API teams should
be solely focused on APIs.
We often see API teams consist
of developers who are also
shared with other projects.
This not only can lead to issues
with resourcing and bandwidth,
but also affect the
direction of your APIs,
such as cutting corners
and striving away
from best practices.
Third, there must be a
willingness to train others
within the organization.
As your API program
grows, so will the demand.
This in turn can lead to
an influx of APIs that will
need to be created or enhanced.
Chances are the API team that
you start off with will expand,
and as new members
are brought in,
they need to be trained
on the foundational design
philosophies you've
already established.
In the world of APIs and the
consumer focused approach,
a consistent API
experience is key.
Fourth, the API team should have
a direct line to the business.
There shouldn't be any
silos between the business
and technical teams.
Makes sense, right?
If the API team has a better
understanding of the business
vision and the impacts
to the end consumers,
the better the APIs
will be, since they
will ensure that the business
vision is properly achieved.
Finally, the API
team should be free
from pre-existing constraints.
As we mentioned
before, the API team
should strive on
innovation and not
be constrained by outdated
governance models or processes.
In the world of
APIs, time to market
is critical, so welcome
change rather than
trying to fit it within
an insufficient process.
In closing we totally understand
of the concept discussed
in this video may seem a little
challenging, especially if you
already have a
governance or delivery
structure in place today.
Remember that the start always
requires the greatest effort,
but if you can overcome
these challenges
and embrace the ideas
we just covered,
you have a more robust
and innovative API team.
Thank you.